[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's brief video i'm going to be
discussing the exciting upcoming harry
potter game
hogwarts legacy the trailer for the much
anticipated game
was released just four months ago and
has incited much fan interest
garnering an astonishing 18 million
views in that short amount of time
hogwarts legacy is a harry potter game
which boasts
an open world format that we haven't had
in the harry potter games of the past
i have a certain love for the old harry
potter games but this new one looks
promising
very promising an open world
single-player action role-playing game
which will allow you to create your own
personal witch or wizard and spec them
exactly as you want them to be
the game takes place around 100 years
before harry potter starts attending
hogwarts
and we the player will run through the
game as a student of hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
during the late 1800s hogwarts legacy
lets players create their own ritual
wizard
select their hogwarts house and explore
an open world hogwarts setting which
includes the castle
forbidden forest and hogsmeade as a
hogwarts student
players will be able to attend classes
brew potions tame fantastic beasts
learn new spells and more the prospect
of the game's release is exciting to say
the least
however the bad news is that the game's
release date has just recently been
pushed back
where initially it was suggested that we
could expect a 2021 release
a statement has since been posted on the
hogwarts legacy twitter account
that confirms fans will now have to wait
until 2022
we would like to thank fans from around
the world and the tremendous reaction to
the announcement of hogwarts legacy
from our port key games label creating
the best possible experience of all the
wizarding world
and gaming fans is paramount to us so
we're giving the game the time it needs
hogwarts legacy will be released in 2022
developers have been working on the game
for a long time and we know this because
early leaked footage of the game first
surfaced as far back as october 2018
however i see this as a good thing it
means they really want it to be a
success
they're really putting a lot of effort
into it in conclusion
it has been both a good and bad week for
harry potter fans as in spite of
hogwarts legacy being pushed back
fans may have an hbo harry potter show
on the horizon
to look forward to if you want to learn
more about that then check out the video
i released a few days ago
link in description that's it for
today's video until next time
remember people find it far easier to
forgive others for being wrong
than being right
[Music]